lahoucine guide marquer sa famille dans
la médina destination la maison de leurs
votes marocain j'écris les français
passeront leur première nuit bonjour
merci j'avais vu dans les propositions
de vision du monde qui avait la
possibilité de passer les nuits et les
soirées shinobi temps je trouvais ça
beaucoup plus intéressante on passe déjà
trop peu de temps dans le pays son vin
tout petit peu sentir les choses c'est
pas mal voyager autrement cela commence
comme ça une visite de la vieille ville
de marrakech que leur accompagnement
proposer leurs fournitures ce moment la
marque sa compagne ses trois enfants
l'attendaient depuis longtemps ça vieux
projet c'est évidemment quand même
partir à 5 c c'est pas simple non plus
ne serait-ce que financièrement donc un
plusieurs années que je pense à partir
dans une démarche de ce type là où des
barges pour c'est parti avec les enfants
un par un et puis finalement les partis
de tous en même temps
marrakech n'est fini la famille doit
passer quinze jours dans un village de
l'atlas à 80 c'est là où les villageois
les accueillent à bras ouverts
ils savent que ces touristes participent
par leur venue au développement de leurs
valises en est encore à inter le whisky
berner l'idée c'est de développer un
tourisme équitable durable et solidaire
aussi en collaboration avec les
habitants du village de trio ya dix
groupes d'âge ans qui passe ils me
demandent de tarifs je refuse parce
qu'on ne gagnait pas grand chose avec
avec leur salaire alors nous on a essayé
de mettre en place les prix convenable
on ne pense il ya un pourcentage qui
passe sur le projet développement ce qui
est très important
tu vois le champ comment il a partagé
avec des petits tas lui les villageois
vous lire les ou potel au village ils
ont pu le faire grâce aux 3 % reversé
sur chaque voyage par les organisateurs
maintenant ça facilite pas mal de choses
plus qu'il a bu l'eau dans les robinets
avant il y avait pas d robinet mais
c'était dur des pluies s'il n'y a pas
d'eau dans l'ain puis il faut le
chercher plus loin
bel âge d'or bat voyait 10 15 ans il y
avait 5000 habitants culminant il soit
treize mille habitants sur la sur la
vallée donc si tous ces projets peuvent
aider notamment à éviter l'exode rural à
permettre aux gens de rester ici et il
ya repeupler une vallée qui dès qu'il ya
de l'eau et du travail et tout ce qu'il
faut aller match le village du bac les
one et le village détail au bas d
environ 65 familles l'importance de
l'application de la population de code
c'est eux qui est bon garder les projets
après la finalisation par exemple le
projet du barclays ou sur l'eau potable
quand on le finit si les villageois qui
vont aller le récupérer et c'est eux qui
vont entretenir le projet après le
départ des anciens du tout
loin des tours opérators lahoucine
hassan et les habitants d'haïti louve en
concocter un programme de randonnées aux
petits oignons à la famille bulteau des
vacances utiles et surtout une vraie
expérience de vie